very happy even if there's a sort of
direction
[Music]
roaring mouse
okay so go ahead and get started our
last speaker for the ring of the last
long talk of the day before all the tour
toxin afternoon is lower balsano
University of Michigan she's going to be
talking about some work act of cluster
English thank you yeah thank you for the
introduction thank you so much for the
invitation this has been a really
educational week I am new to active
learning and so I've really enjoyed
hearing all the different perspectives
I'm going to talk about work that is
mostly due to my student John who's here
and so you can of course direct
questions to both of us at any time and
it's on active clustering with union of
subspace structure which I will get into
to each one of those topics so of course
everyone this whole week has talked
about all the different motivations for
active learning where really the the
central philosophy is one that's been
around for centuries where we look for a
measurement we can take that the
difference between our prediction and
what we're going to observe is maybe has
enough uncertainty that we can learn
something by training our measurements
in that area ok so we've heard about
applications this week that use Amazon
Mechanical Turk users to label uncertain
images that take make biological
experiments for certain drugs or genes
that we have some uncertainty about and
then work that I've done also with my
student John and actively sampling
environmental spatial signals and trying
to train our robot to go to areas where
there's uncertainty in the signal okay
but not only do we have to focus on this
uncertainty but we need to make some
assumptions as aarthi just said and many
other people have said about what's the
kind of straw
sure smoothness or underlying the data
okay so maybe in clustering we're
assuming that the data are kind of
cohesive within certain classes or maybe
if data aren't that cohesive at least
their labels seem to transition smoothly
across space at least after some kind of
transformation in this spatial sampling
signal or sampling application maybe we
assume that there are some smoothness
across space and the Phenom phenomenon
we're interested in well today the kind
of structure that I'm going to focus on
is called the union of subspace
structure where we assume that different
points from different classes of data
lie very close to low dimensional sub
spaces okay and we'll get in a little
later to what the sort of different
challenges of this model are but it
definitely happens to fit a lot of data
sets that these other kinds of
assumptions don't typically fit okay so
I want to start by telling you a little
bit about me and my research so I have
only started working on active learning
in the past few years since John joined
my group and was very excited about
active learning I had learned a little
bit by osmosis from some of my
colleagues before that but my main focus
of research is on using structure to do
inference with messy data okay so for
example I've worked on problems in
structured single index models where we
observe some data why that conditioned
on and a predictor variable X has a
relationship that's dictated by maybe
some unknown nonlinear function okay so
I've worked on this in the context of
environmental calibration where you have
some unknown calibration function that's
affecting your sensor signals and you
may assume for example that this matrix
is low rank and you can use that
structure in order to also learn the
calibration I've worked in me
trix factorization or matrix completion
with streaming data more recent work on
understanding subspace structure when
you have heteroscedasticity and then
I've worked in the past on estimating
union of subspace structure where
different columns of your matrix come
from different sub spaces but with
missing entries okay I'm trying to
complete such a matrix in active
learning we got started in this area on
a problem that's a spatial sampling
problem not the one I'm going to talk
about today but it's very interesting if
you're interested I encourage you to ask
us later or take a look at the paper we
have on archive we have a little a
little boat it swims through the lake
and we're interested in sampling certain
properties of the water for example in
some of the major lakes around Michigan
we're looking for low oxygen
concentration because that's what you
get algae blooms and other bad toxic
events happening in the lake and if you
remember talks earlier in the week
talking about taking a spatial signal
like this and using some kind of binary
search around it a transition point our
work here was to do something like that
but to also penalize for the fact that
this is a picture of lake erie it's
gigantic this boat well he's not the one
who swam on lake erie yet but even if we
get a bigger one it'll only be the size
of say a surfboard we don't want him
going to the middle of the interval to
perform binary search before he learns
anything about the signal right so we
had something we call quantile search
that trades off between the distance
physical distance that's traveled and
the informativeness of each sample and
this has been deployed even on sister
lake so these are actual measurements
taken
buy this boat in that picture so so this
you know this work and the work I'm
going to talk about today those are my
only two experiences with active
learning so I say that as not a caveat
so much as an invitation if you have
questions or if they're things that you
know you want to comment on I'm very
excited to hear about them and learn
from all of you because as many people
have said many of the things I'm going
to do have you know a lot of the
foundational results were proven by
people who are sitting in this room
which is really cool so great to be a
part of and one last sort of personal
thing about me and my maybe history
perhaps is that in the last month I got
married so and I and I don't say just
because I'm happy and excited and
seeking attention or anything but or
showing off our handsome this handsome
couple but actually just to say I've
been really busy you know so if my if
the answer to your question isn't in my
slides then I just been busy i'm still
writing thank you notes you know just
give me a break here and i'm happy to
answer whatever questions you have okay
so here's the the outline first i'll
tell you about the union of subspaces
model the kind of challenges we have in
this model that are different from other
things that are typically used
structural assumptions and then i'm
going to define something that I call
subspace margin which is somewhat
analogous to margin in a classifier okay
introduce our algorithm we call super
PAC also inspired by the political
season subspace clustering with pairwise
active constraints and show you some
results on data okay so subspace
representations are good for a lot of
data okay so how will we know if our
particular data set is well represented
by a linear subspace so perhaps
you want to sense a length and vector of
temperatures from a sensor network or or
pixels from an image or features from an
image then you collect many of those
signals so you have several of these
lengths and signals you can do a
singular value decomposition and look at
the best rank K or whatever rank you're
interested in subspace projection of
those sensors of those signals and when
you look at the singular values it's
very very common in every data set that
I've ever looked at it's just a question
of how quickly they drop off the
singular values are large and then there
are many many many singular values that
are nearly zero or very very small ok so
our data are well approximated then by
some low dimensional subspace maybe not
exactly of course but with some additive
noise ok now in a lot of machine
learning problems we also need to think
about a mixture of these subspaces ok so
image data of different objects
handwritten digits or faces is often
approximated with the low dimensional
subspace model but different faces tend
to have kind of different sub spaces in
the space and so we want to think about
this mixture and try to leverage that
structure in these problems so what
happens when we have a mixture of
subspaces what are the kind of
challenges we face so this is just
saying we have all these columns we
don't know which one maybe belongs to
which subspace but this is how the
subspace might look so if data are
coming from these subspaces the first
thing we notice is that there's no
separator right we can't even find some
nonlinear function that will separate
these two classes in a higher
dimensional space and so we have to deal
with that fact another important
consideration is that sometimes when you
have subspaces of different sizes one
sub space like this green one may
completely contain
another subspace like this blue one ok
so the load one dimensional subspace is
a line within the higher dimensional
subspace now still you might want to
learn from this data if there are a lot
of data clustered around this line and
then other data kind of spread
throughout that subspace you could
presumably still learn those two
different subspaces right but it's still
a challenge to think one clusters and
entirely is entirely contained in
another and then a last one is that when
you have multiple subspaces of higher
dimension they have a non-trivial or
they could have a non-trivial
intersection ok sometimes they must but
they could have and that just means that
points in this subspace even though
these are quite distinct subspaces could
be arbitrarily close to the other
subspace and in fact could lie in the
intersection and you'd have to try to
figure out how to just how to
distinguish those two so these are the
main challenges that arise when dealing
with union of subspace data now it's a
it's a sort of very natural clustering
problem we have this nice model there
have been many different algorithms to
try to do this clustering in an
unsupervised way for a long time but the
more recent ones actually have some very
nice theory to provably recover the
clusters in a variety of these
configurations ok probably the most
popular one is sparse subspace
clustering this one here that has had
several different theoretical works
taking a look at how to guarantee that
you recover all the different subspaces
from the clustered data and the way
sparse subspace clustering works is it
leverages something we call self
expressiveness so you take each data
point individually outside of
out of the data set and then you regress
it on to the remaining data points so
you try to fit your data point to all
the other ones and using an l1 norm you
can say well then I'll have a very small
number of other points they select this
one then a very small number of these
other ones will be used to describe my
held out point and what these methods or
what the theory around these methods
proves is that actually it will only
select points in that l1 regression that
are also from the same subspace and so
as a result you have always points that
will should be clustered together will
have nonzero coefficients in the l1
regression and there are several other
algorithms to with other types of
guarantees in a variety of contexts now
what's cool is that they also work
pretty well on real data okay so that
doesn't necessarily satisfy their
assumptions perfectly but classification
error for SSC on the Yale faces which is
the example I've been using in an
illustration as far as it can get eight
percent classification error okay that
seems really quite good amnesty jets are
a little bit less nice for the subspace
assumption but still can get thirty
percent classification error with all 10
digits you know in the data set so and
this is the best of the three algorithms
on that data set but that said this is
actually still worse than what I'm going
to call the Oracle union of subspaces
and let me explain what I mean by that
so let's say I take the data in
retrospect and I know the or you know
before or with the the true labeled data
and I take each class everyone that's
for a certain object every image for a
certain object and I run PCA and I take
the best rank 10 subspace that fits that
cluster right so
so using the same size of subspace as
these algorithms we're using I fit the
best subspace to each cluster then I
forget the labels and just use those sub
spaces and project the data onto each
subspace and do class or do clustering
or classification according to the
closest subspace okay so I have the sort
of Oracle best subspaces basically and I
look at how to classify the data based
on those then it gets a lot better error
so less than 1% for the Yale faces and
seven percent for the amnesty jutt okay
so actually the union of subspace model
is strong if we find the right sub
spaces and we're going to do a good job
and these algorithms are doing well but
not finding the best sub spaces for some
reason so this is the kind of thing we
were thinking about when we started
incorporating active learning into this
problem I guess there's two sides one
first can we get to what the Oracle can
do and then of course if the Oracle
still has errors there's always some
points that are at least under this
model not closest to their sort of
cluster Center so we need labels in
order to make sure we can classify them
yeah so maybe in that statement it seems
like there is some implicit assumption
going there the classification labels
have some meaning in terms of these
subspaces in the data and that may or
may not always be true right it could
just be that the labels are sort of
orthogonal information and when you do
the Oracle approach obviously you are
relating the two there as your
unsupervised method never gets to see
that information so what do you think
there's always a reasonable thing to
assume that the subspaces are going to
be related to the classification tables
um so I'm not sure that for every data
said it's a reasonable thing to say that
each cluster is a different low
dimensional subspace but that's sort of
the thing I'm positing and presenting
this algorithm
for data like that right so for example
in this case the fact that i can give
you a collection of subspaces i got them
in this way of looking at the labels but
i can give you a collection of subspaces
that if I just use those to cluster I
get say less than 1 percent error so
it's an excellent model for those data
right does that answer you you could
sort of alternatively think that when
you're just letting the unsupervised
version lose on the data maybe it's
picking up some other latent
characteristics of the data set which
may or may not be directly expression
directly but maybe you could pray in
another kind of classifier on top of
that which will be so maybe they are
just providing a modern they might still
be providing a more informaiton
representation for learning at last fall
but may not directly isolate the label
in terms of you know just like looking
at each cluster okay thanks I think yeah
no no I think I understand and I'd want
to talk to you more about it later but
you know maybe if we think for now of
these algorithms I mentioned as as
outputting not just maybe of clustering
or a representation but subspaces in
particular and sort of using those for
clustering so we're sort of comparing on
that axis yeah I think the question is
not about assumptions with no
definitions I mean we don't have a
definition of correct clustering so here
you take is a definition the clustering
that corresponds to the classification
as a definition of what is your correct
clustering but we don't have an accepted
or unique definition of correct
clustering so it's a tomato defining
what is the goal and not so much of
assumptions yeah okay then now I
understand the question a little bit
better so you know the applications that
i'm going to show you in all cases we
have a correct clustering right we want
to put all the faces of the same person
or all the objects of the same type into
the same cluster but in general if we
apply we can apply these unsupervised
methods to any data set where you know
the actual correct labeling may be
different based on different goals or
different points
and so yeah I mean yeah I understand
better now making function or
distribution played on it subspace but
you haven't generated more yeah so and
then I think in that case this you know
this what we're going to talk about
today would be a little more appropriate
because we're really relying on the
subspace model that that the class label
is tied to the subspace that it's
closest to and then a generative model
would generate something like that any
other questions
okay so let's just look really briefly
at some plots I come back to these later
so I'm not trying to get into detail now
but the these plots are showing on the
excess x-axis the number of pairwise
constraints that we request that's the
type of label that I'll talk about later
on the y-axis the Miss classification
rate and the reason why I want to show
these first is to see okay we have this
like dotted line is this Oracle that I
just talked about that's the
classification rate you could get with
this sort of best PC a fit and it's not
you know it's not zero but it's lower
than many of these other or than the
starting point of these algorithms which
is going to be the unsupervised method
and what we want is to try to use as few
labels as possible in order to get down
to this level and then down to zero
percent clustering air okay so that's
the goal in which labels you select in
what order has an impact on then how you
can do a better job of subspace
clustering your data
let's see so this one let's take for
example has 64 images / subspace and I
don't remember exactly the size of each
image but yeah 64 image so this is 640
total
okay so we just wanted to just quickly
mention in order to motivate what we do
a little bit later we use spectral
clustering within our active algorithm
and these algorithms not in all not in
all their theoretical guarantees but in
some of them out put an affinity matrix
and use spectral clustering and so to
get guarantees they talked about how
this affinity matrix has no false
connection so the only nonzero entries
are where to two data points should be
in the same cluster and all the other
ones are 0 and so spectral clustering
will work very well in that scenario
something I think is interesting as
spectral clustering also works more
generally and and more recently or seems
to empirically and more recently there's
a lot of interesting theoretical results
on regularizing spectral clustering
based on sort of the sparsity structure
of your measurements of the affinity
matrix and for stochastic bluff models
we know that as long as the spectral gap
is big enough in the expected affinity
matrix then we can use this you know
regular eyes version of spectral
clustering to recover it so while some
of these guarantees require this nice
clean no false connections I believe
that it shouldn't be need to be quite
that restrictive but probably and that's
what we see in practice you can have an
affinity matrix that's not quite as
clean but spectral clustering will
recover the cluster structure okay so
let's go on and talk about then how do
we select which points that we're going
to consider or and ask the labels for
and the way that we define this notion
is sort of analogous to margin and
classification so first I just wanted to
comment you know people have talked
about
different classification and clustering
active clustering techniques and people
have different ideas of when these words
should be used or what they mean right
so maybe somehow classically clustering
is an unsupervised problem we don't have
any labels we just have points we don't
have a perfect clustering we need to
minimize some you know some distance
metric or some overall metric and find
unsupervised clustering where is
classification even with multiple
classes we have at least some data we
can ask for labels and then we use those
in order to maybe transduce labels
across the data set or whatever it is
but we incorporate labels into
classification but I think another way
that we use it sort of colloquially is
that actually in clustering the clusters
are kind of cohesive right they have
something in common and then in between
clusters we have some disparities and
maybe in classification more what we can
hope for is just some kind of separation
but not necessarily that we get
something some cohesive behavior within
a class okay so these are sort of i
think you know that's why we talk about
active clustering because in my example
we have clusters of subspaces and we can
use that kind of in class cohesiveness
we know that all of them should be kind
of close to this subspace and we
leverage that to do a better job okay so
just to think about classifier margin
for a second if we have data that comes
from perhaps two gaussians like I've
drawn here we could select a small
number of these to label as coming from
the first or the second and find perhaps
the best linear classifier given the
points we've seen so far maybe we have a
decision region that looks something
like this after just seeing a few labels
and we think of the margin as a region
around the decision boundary ok so the
region where perhaps we have the most
uncertain
so in an active margin classifier we
would start with a larger larger margin
because we have very few labels and then
we will sample the label for some points
within that margin for some small subset
and then just using that small subset we
re learn a new classifier with the
smaller margin and iterate ok so our
notion of subspace margin is going to be
similar we don't have separate regions
of space but we certainly have decision
regions there discontinuous but you know
we know that over near this subspace we
believe the data to be in the blue
cluster and here in the red cluster and
so we're going to define a similar kind
of margin which is near these decision
Regents but is a kind of angular margin
I suppose so you know if you're close to
this by this decision boundary by angle
then you're an uncertain point not sure
which subspace it should be assigned to
and will query on those points yeah i
mean the picture is when when you're
subspaces intersect in a single point
but you have more than two subspaces
then they may have different points of
the sections of its not taken out of
geometrically the definition yeah so
I'll show the definition next and you
can imagine that like say there's
another subspace here so it's looking at
the region that's the most sort of in
between subspaces so the points that
could be equally distant from two so
let's say there was one line here then
this will still be the margin but in
here we would get some kind of block
that would go to the two other corners
the least referenced one cluster
exactly so let's look at how that gets
defined in a subspace so we have a sub
space in our in our collection so this
is you can think of as like existing
positive estimate that we think these
subspaces are modeling our data it has a
projection matrix 0 for every point we
have a distance to that subspace it's
the residual error from the point to its
projection okay so we're going to take
our margin to be 1 minus the distance to
our true subspace ok / the next closest
subspace so if we're very far from the
truth subspace and equally far from the
other one for example a point that's in
here somewhere then it's going to have a
low margin this term will be 1 and 1
minus that will be small ok so we want a
sample small margin points in this way
and I just define this term here to be
mu because we're going to look at that
on the next slide so points out here
will be high margin points and points
closer to the decision boundary will be
low margin points ok and this then would
generalize to other sub spaces and of
other dimensions and so on oh yeah so in
general we of course like a sub K are to
be
yeah yeah so well and also here I've
sort of written it like this because I
prove something about this particular
Mew but you know what we use in the
algorithm is the distance to the closest
divided by the distance to the
second-closest because we don't know we
don't only compute margin on the points
we know their label we computed on other
one so that we can decide which ones to
juice so there another question ok so
let's see then what we can say about
this definition of margin ok so we have
two dimensional sub spaces in a larger
capital D dimensional space and I'm
going to observe a noisy point and ask
basically how does this margin
concentrate so my my point X is in one
of the subspaces it's in s1 and all I
observe is y which is X corrupted with a
little bit of Gaussian noise ok and what
this very standard concentration result
shows is that the margin of that noisy
point is bit you know depends on some
ratio that's very close to one but then
affected by the residual of the true
point X to the other subspace ok so if
that true point x is very far away from
the other subspace then we're going to
have that the residual is the norm of X
right and these are both going to be
small but on the other hand if this term
is 0 then we get something a margin or
at least mu that's very close to zero
and then a margin that's very small ok
so this sort of leads us to understand
that points near the intersection of
subspaces are the ones that have the low
margin they have a small residual to the
other sub space so it's near to the
intersection okay and that's nice
because it's well known at least from
practice that it's really the points
near the intersection of these subspaces
that's causing trouble for the
algorithms okay that when we actually
run it or any even in the theoretical
results have to sort of make assumptions
on how close those near points can be
dunzo genitive assumption yes yeah X is
in the subspace yeah and and again
that's why I defined this with K star
with the true subspace so this is saying
its closest subspace and then the next
closest the ratio of those two
you
okay so and we can see a corollary of
this theorem I want to go through it
it's a little bit more technical but I
think it it's nice because it it sort of
displays this relationship that I'm
trying to talk about like how close
should appoint be near the intersection
for it to have a very low margin but to
get there I need to make sure that we're
on the same page about the idea the
notion of principle angles excuse me so
how many of you are familiar with
principal angles between two subspaces
what the definition of that would mean
okay a few but that's the slide is going
to be useful then okay so if we have to
d dimensional sub spaces in any space
they share d principal angles between
them okay so these are drawn to be in
pseudo three-dimensional space so
imagine this is to two dimensional sub
spaces in three-dimensional space in
this case the first angle is zero so any
two subspaces that have a non-trivial
intersection have a zero angle between
them okay so in the way that you
identify it is to find the two vectors
one in the red one in the green subspace
that have the smallest angle between
them of course in this case they share
an intersection so you can find them the
two points right there in the
intersection okay and then to find the
the next angle in this case we only have
two but more generally it's a recursive
definition you remove that direction
from both subspaces look at the
orthogonal vectors so I've drawn this
one is orthogonal to that one in the red
subspace and this one as orthogonal to
that one in the green subspace okay and
then the angle between those next
vectors that you have is the remaining
in this case principal angle between the
two so let's say that's about 30 degrees
and what matters here the reason why
this is important is because how these
angles behave completely dictates how
far a point in one subspace can be to
the other right so say for example the
smallest angle is not zero say it's 90
degrees so now we're in a much higher
dimensional space and we have fully
orthogonal subspaces then every point in
the red subspace is orthogonal to every
point in the green subspace right no
matter when you how you project your
residual will be the full vector you
won't ever have a representation than
the other subspace on the other hand you
can't have any point that's further away
from the other subspace then your
largest principle angle you know if
these guys have the largest principle
angle of 30 degrees then no point is
further than that in the two subspaces
okay and so these these quantities
really dictate what you can do like
basically how much you know deviation
you can get in the margin so we're going
to think about okay we're going to fix
the principal angles and then look at
what the margin looks like okay so let
me go through this a little bit
carefully since it's a technical slide
so we have our our principal angles Phi
1 to Phi D and I want you instead just
to use this gamma as a you know as a
plug-in so just think of it as the
angles its sine of the angle so if it's
small of 0 at 0 if it goes up to 1 but
this is kind of like each angle so our
gamma 1 is the smallest angle gamma D is
the largest one and it's just we have
this for technical technicality to or to
be technically correct as it relates to
these projections okay so what we're
going to do is have our point again
generative that's in one subspace and
this point is the one we're going to
kind of control we're going to say maybe
it's close to the intersection in some
way and how I control that is I'm going
to say it's residual onto the other
subspace well we know I said before it
can't be the residual on to the other
subspace can't be any closer than the
smallest principal angle right that's
the closest it can be so it's going to
be at least that so at least gamma 1
plus something that sort of moves it
into the directions toward the
directions of the other principal angles
okay so this is the average principal
angle so we control Delta or by changing
Delta we bring it closer to the
intersection or further from the
intersection ok so if Delta 0 it's at
the point that is closest to the other
subspace so that's our controlled point
and now consider another point also in
s1 okay but this time drawn uniformly so
just drawn nicely from the subspace the
average point in the subspace so
actually x2's distance to s2 will be
something like the average angle okay
and both of them are corrupted with
additive noise so what we want to be
able to say is that x1 my point that I'm
controlling if i push it close enough to
the intersection its margin will be
smaller than this average random point
okay so that's what this theorem says
the margin of that controlled point the
one that I can push toward the
intersection it will be smaller than the
margin of the average point with high
probability if Delta is small enough so
if it's sort of close enough to the
intersection and the gap between the
smallest angle and the average angle is
big enough okay so you can imagine if
the average angle if all the angles are
0 for example then all the points will
have the same margin you
can't really deal with this if on the
other hand the smallest angle is zero
and all the rest are 90 degrees then you
kind of are close in some directions and
far and others and this margin is a
really good indicator of points that are
near the intersection and the way that
these this Delta and and this gap work
together you know how far X is from the
intersection and then how far apart the
angles are is controlled by this towel
parameter so it comes up in both and the
closer or the smaller is Delta then the
smaller the gap can be and vice versa
okay okay cool so that's the end of the
theoretical results of the talk okay but
we use it as a kind of motivator for
this definition of margin that I've
given and that it finds these points
near the intersection of subspaces are
at the at the closest parts of the
subspaces in order to use an active
labeling technique yes to be able to
drop
um
oh I see what you're saying when I mean
uniformly I mean from some nice
continuous distribution any other
questions
okay okay so let's look at the algorithm
that we do that uses these this notion
of margin okay so first I want to
comment that we're going to use querying
for pairwise constraints we motivate
this just saying well the users that
we're asking may not know the actual
labels they may not know for example the
names of these people or the characters
in another language but they could at
least identify that they're the same
person okay also the users may use
different languages so you know if we
want to identify numbers or objects we'd
have to be able to match all the
different languages together whereas if
we just ask them are these the same
picture then they can say yes or no
right okay so here's what our algorithm
does so we have as input and to fit any
matrix and I mentioned briefly earlier
that we use it from an unsupervised
clustering technique so SSC or really
any technique that outputs an affinity
matrix we start from that and using
spectral clustering we get some cluster
estimate okay so now every point has a
cluster estimate we run PCA on those
clusters so I use this illustration to
show the the red and blue line won't be
aligned necessarily with the the red and
blue points because well some some of
the points from this other subspace seem
to have been clustered there but you get
some approximation okay so using this
PCA approximation we select the text the
test point which has the smallest margin
and on that test point we compare it to
other objects in sets that we call
certain sets okay so this is something
else we initialized you could say maybe
you start just by querying a few
random pairs and you either ask if these
two should be together in which case you
put them in a certain set or if not you
keep worrying until there's no other
object like that and then you put it in
its own new certain set okay so we take
our test point we query against a very
representative image in one of these
certain sets the representativeness is
also chosen by how close it is to its
subspace okay so if it's well
approximated by its subspace and we use
it as a representative and we put it in
the cluster where it gets assigned we
impute label information into the
affinity matrix so for this particular
image we say okay you know it's not
clustered with these or these it is
clustered with those and then we repeat
spectral clustering question about the
algorithm
okay so let me show you how it does ok
so we compared against a very similar
algorithm that this was essentially
inspired by RIT starts with the affinity
matrix and spectral clustering and then
just does this process differently
doesn't assume the subspace model but
assumes an uncertainty reducing way of
selecting the test point but then all
the rest of this is also the same ok we
also compare it against our our setup
but where our query technique uses the
affinity matrix only random set up where
we choose every pair at random and then
of course the Oracle that I mentioned
before ok and this is the plot I showed
earlier you can see that using this
subspace model in all of these
particular examples the number of
queries these pairwise comparisons that
we need in order to get below the union
of subspace Oracle and then down to zero
is much fewer than we need in this
uncertainty reducing model that doesn't
assume a subspace model yes what is the
crown jewel cm is it the generative more
than or do you have labels and you're
trying to match the classes to the
neighbors that's a great question so
this here is the Yale faces data in the
images that I showed before you have
multiple faces so the ground truth is
given that they took images of the same
person and then this one here is the
amnesty data set so again there we you
know asked to write those so we have
ground truth yeah right as I mentioned
before that do you want to call it
multi-class classification or clustering
and the you know the reason why I'm
calling it clustering is because I'm
thinking of these subspace faces is
giving it that kind of cohesive miss but
it's absolutely multi-class
classification too yeah
so you're paralyzed judgment those are
simulated truth labels yeah and cleanly
I guess the question I have is consider
some of the low margin points presumably
from your picture some of them are going
to be right at the intersection or very
close to who what would they look like
in reality right with it just be like a
blackish good vision hey ya know when
you do see like in this data set these
are better examples there are some where
they turned the light down very low and
that's why we kind of get those points
near the zero intersection so that's a
great question i think and we haven't
done it we've thought about it loosely
but we haven't done it yet it would be
very interesting to instead well either
have real people doing those pairwise
queries or have some kind of noise model
where the closer it gets to that let's
say some true margin or to some true
intersection the noisier the label is
because my definition the point right
out of this action can get on to both
humans have no wait
right no that's absolutely right so it's
a really important caveat to make in
this yeah that when we run these we have
a computer that knows the label even
though there may be two black images
that's a good question all of them were
between five and 12 do you remember for
EM NIST not off the top of your head
yeah that's enough yeah yeah all of them
were between five and 12 yeah or 15 one
of them was 15 any other questions
ok so this table is just to kind of show
you how our algorithm scales with the
different size oh here here we have the
little D is the is the subspace
dimension that we use and we we chose
that typically based on previous papers
that had said they use that for some
reason or other and we wanted to do a
comparison so our algorithm is slower
than this uncertainty reducing algorithm
when d is larger the capital d the full
subspace dimension and it does better
when d is more moderate and the number
of points is large so we're we're
efficient as the number of points growth
much more than the other algorithms okay
here's another interesting plot so this
is another collection of digits from the
united states postal service data set
it's a little Messier and a couple
things to point out I guess that this
uncertainty reducing algorithm struggles
quite a bit it's a very large data set
it's the one over here so here was about
48 hours of running and we just stopped
there but the other thing that's
interesting is the sort of spiky
behavior we're getting from spectral
clustering here that we don't understand
yet except to see that for some reason
one label imputation has changed the
clustering significantly but then after
another label it seems to come back
right and so we saw this also in the
coil data set this is an object images
of different objects we saw that kind of
spike eNOS with fewer clusters anyway
and it was really quite simple to just
implement a heuristic that looked at a
sequence of resulting clusterings and
picked some kind of you know or ignored
ones when they change significantly and
came back to something more similar
so it's pretty simple to just smooth
those things out with a heuristic like
that but whether there's an you know
deeper theoretical understanding remains
to be seen
yeah you said it either to 0 or 1 mm-hmm
and then here are a few other
experiments that came from the this
paper of you rass the uncertainty
reducing algorithm just to kind of show
that a well a couple of things first
that the super PAC algorithm you know
whether there is subspace structure or
not in these data sets it doesn't seem
to do worse right so it may be that this
sort of subspace model is also somewhat
general okay but then also we considered
another type of another type of querying
behavior where we called it active
random so what we mean by that is that
the only thing we do we still have a
feedback loop instead of just to
choosing two points that random to query
from the whole data set we use the
feedback loop and in this stage where we
make a test query we choose that one at
random and we choose a certain set at
random to compare it to okay but you
know just the fact of using feedback is
clearly all all by itself something
that's also really useful here you know
in an interesting conclusion I think for
this crowd that these other techniques
are trying to use some fancy uncertainty
or a subspace model or whatever but just
using a feedback driven model as doing
as well and some of these data sets okay
so in conclusion you know I from my
previous research and everything want to
just impress that low rank signal
structure helps in many problems and in
these last examples it doesn't also seem
to hurt and in a particular case of this
generative subspace clustering model are
our definition of subspace margin
provides some kind of match
for nearness to the the intersection and
as I've alluded to we're very interested
in understanding more carefully you know
when this algorithm should work what
types of mistakes that might make or
what kind of theory we can give to it so
thank you for your attention and I'll
take any more questions so you know what
I think you'd be really interesting is
to allow each class in the set all
subspace this pictures that would suck
it covers a Nashville huh yeah you could
approximate it with several low
dimensional sub spaces yeah sounds like
if I just generalize please I think it
would actually because um you know if we
could show something about this then the
next sort of step would be that if you
have the subspaces then you would simply
need some kind of metric for knowing
when they go together you know when and
you may even be able to actively query
for labels on that when you should patch
these few subspaces into one bigger
cluster but we could certainly you know
from what we have here learn each sort
of piecewise component and then the
question would just be putting them
together
yeah for each point I make Brandon
comparisons to some small notes right
like a lot make the point and then I
make I don't compare them to all other
points but just some randomly chosen
subset and they do that for each point
so like I take a logarithmic number of
comparison for each point and then try
to do this both possible like today make
sure have enough kind of some level of
basic density isn't pretty China I think
I understand so definitely picked some
reasonably small number of comparisons
for each item or object I'm bound to get
at least one that will be in the same
cluster inside something like k log K or
something right yeah yeah I see what
you're saying um be better than just
purely random
yeah something in between what we were
trying to say of using feedback because
it wouldn't be using feedback but it's
more than just choosing totally random
pairs and maybe what you're saying is to
have the goal to find must link
constraints basically because you can
imagine if you choose pairs at random
then you find more cannot link
constraints than must link whereas so
what active random does is instead of
have you know some smart way of
selecting the test point it selects here
randomly but then and then selects which
order of these to query but so in the
same way it finds something and it finds
a must link so maybe you're onto
something that it's the question of
those muscling Xia graph uh-huh right
right yeah I guess it would be a little
bit more sensitive to noise right you'd
have to think a little harder with that
but also we don't know how robust this
is yeah that's a good point yeah how
much of this just translates to the case
where your clusters are
so like a translator fine subspace ya
know it it generalizes I guess you know
you have to do an affine projection and
you have to do an affine pca but um it's
those different clusters are translated
differently this kind totally still
handle that yeah so you would just
instead of you know finding a zero-mean
subspace you would look for first the
mean vector of your data and then
subtract it and find the low dimensional
subspace and then you would do a fine
projection on that as well does that
make sense
and margin also generalizes to that case
because it's just defined so you know
you just have your distance we defined
as the affine projection
okay thanks again for your attention
[Applause]